deep within the Arctic more than 1200 Mi
north of Moscow lies Russia's most
notorious prison camp FK I3 also known
as Polar wolf Locos call the prison the
end of the world and it's not hard to
see why located near the village of karp
inside the Arctic Circle polar wolf is
completely cut off from the outside
world and it's the perfect place to send
Russia's most dangerous prisoners to rot
the prison camp is home to all the most
violent types of criminals you would
expect murderers thieves spies and
traitors but it also houses another
special class of prisoners political
disson like Alexa navali navali is one
of Putin's most feared political
opponents in 2020 Putin tried to have
him poison with a deli nerve agent but
he survived so Putin had to resort to
the next best thing throwing navali in
jail on Trump up charges at first navali
was held in a prison near Moscow but on
December 5th 2023 he disappeared Without
a Trace navali happened feeling sick the
week before he went missing so when his
lers and family suddenly lost contact
with him and the jail said that he had
been removed people assumed the worst
either he had died from his illness or
the Russian authorities had killed him
for 20 days no one knew where navali was
or even if he was alive but then on
December 26 nal's lawyers revealed that
they have finally trapped him down to
the polar wolf prison camp in the Arctic
Circle Nali has spent almost 3 weeks
being transported in a complicated
transit to the most notorious and most
remote prison in Russia through his
lawyers navali finally managed to get a
message to his followers don't worry
about me I'm fine I'm awfully glad I
finally made it here End quotes but if
navali thought that SP 3 weeks moving
from one Russian prison to the next was
the worst of it he had a nasty surprise
waiting for him in polar wolf see
there's very little we know about this
Jail at the end of the world only a
handful of pictures even exist online
and since even fewer inmates ever make
it out alive finding someone with inside
knowledge about what it's like is not
easy but there have been a very few ex-
prisoners that have come forward and
what they have to say about the Arthur
prison is terrifying according to them
if the freezing temperatures and
physical abuse doesn't kill you the
psychological torture and total
isolation will make you want to do it to
yourself and this is what Alex navali
has to look forward to 20 years in the
Arctic hellhole designed to break every
cell in your being this is what it's
like inside Russia's most brutal
[Music]
prison you'll probably never have to
experience the horrors of a Russian
prison but if you're still facing the
horrors of having to wrestle a clunky
old wallet out of your pants well then
you got to pick up an extra wallet xter
makes the smartest wallets out there
they're rfad blocking so not only do
they protect your cards from being
skimmed but they're also super classy
and oh so satisfying to use I've been
using mine for 3 years now and it's the
only wallet I will ever use and they've
got some cool new designs that you can
check out they're super slim while still
being able to carry the perfect amount
of cards plus cash extra solar powered
tracker means you're never going to lose
it the tracker allows you you to also
ring your wallet from your phone plus
you can turn on alerts to get notified
when you leave your wallet behind and
they also have models that you can add
an Apple Air tag to if you're still
using an old thick wallet now is the
time to upgrade because xar is offering
up to 45% off to celebrate the new year
just go to partner. xer.com J Tran and
use promo code Jake Tran to take
advantage of the offer and psds are my
favorite gifts to give out people always
love them and because the New Year won't
be new forever this offer will expire
soon so pause the video right now and
click the link
below
Alexa navali is one of pun's most
outspoken political opponents since the
mid 2000s navali has accused the Russian
government of widespread corruption and
election fraud which let's be honest
he's probably 100% correct about and
he's run into all sorts of trouble for
it in 2017 navali was attacked twice by
someone spraying a bright green chemical
in his face the chemical caused severe
burns and navali lost 80% of his sight
in his right eye but still naali refused
to back down in July 2017 he was
arrested and kept in jail for 25 days
for organizing illegal protest in
October of that same year he was
sentenced to another 20 days in jail for
the same thing but over and over again
Nali refused to be silenced instead he
accused dozens of Russian businesses and
oligarchs of corruption and he
eventually took on Putin himself calling
his government quote a party of crooks
and thieves End quotes and with that it
was the final straw the Russian
government wasn't going to sit quietly
on the silence while some bleeding heart
activists drag them through the mud so
in August 2020 on a flight to Moscow
Nali suddenly became dangerously Sick by
the time the plan made an emerg he
Landing navali was in a coma and doctors
were fighting to save his life as it
turns out he had been poisoned with a
military gr nerve agent called Nova
choke one of the Russian intelligence
Services go to poisons to take care of
Putin's political opponents still
struggling to fight off the effects of
the poison navali was evacuated to
Germany for better treatments and
surprisingly he survived but even more
surprising was that after just 5 months
of recovering in Germany navali made the
decision to go back to Russia his plane
had barely landed when Russian
authorities arrested Nali for violating
the conditions of his parole related to
some previous charge it didn't matter
that he left for medical reasons or that
his life was in danger Putin wanted Nali
gone for good so soon after his arrest
navali was sentenced to 2 and 1/2 years
in jail but 2 and 1/2 years just wasn't
enough so a year later our court found
him guilty of extremism and extended his
sentence by another 19 years Putin's
message to all the would be activists
out there was clear if you go against me
I'll make sure you never see the light
of day again and so navali was facing 20
years in prison at first Nali was held
at a relatively low security prison near
Moscow even though he was often kept in
isolation at least he could see his
lawyers and receive letters on a regular
basis but that was just a little bit too
much comfort for Putin for Putin just
keeping him in a regular jail wasn't bad
enough he wanted naali to suffer he
wanted navali to be the example so that
everyone knows what happens when you
step out of line and so in December 2023
navali was secretly transfer to the
polar wolf prison camp the most remote
feared and secretive prison camp in all
of the country and if you think polar
wolf is anything like the super max
presence we have in the US boy you would
be sadly
[Music]
mistaken in Russia's prison system
prison camps are prison colonies like
polar wolf sit at the top of the pyramid
while regular Russian jails house white
color and alltime criminals and
first-time offenders prison camps are
designed for only the worst of the worst
see most Russian prison camps Trace
their history back to the force labor
camps or the Googs of the Soviet Union
this is the gag on the outside gulags
were Joseph Stalin's sick way of
punishing people who opposed them but
that was only half of the truth in
reality gulags were just a great source
of Free Labor think about it if you're a
maniacal dictator that wants to build
your Empire well an Empire where
railroads and mines and roads aren't
going to build themselves and your sure
as hell not going to pay your people to
build for you so what do you do you
force them to do the labor with Force
labor camps why do you think every
dictator regime around the world employs
forc labor camps it's because they work
and that is why over the decades
Millions upon millions of people were in
prison in gcks all over the Soviet Union
where they were forced into hard labor
tortured starve and often killed when
the cold war finally ended instead of
destroying the Googs the Russian
government simply did a lit rebranding
instead of Googs they would be called a
much nicer sounding name prison colonies
the new Russian government needed to at
least try to look Humane so instead of
just executing and starving prisoners
right away they would just Haack on so
many life sentences that you were
guaranteed to die in the prison camp
anyways same effect and they also made
sure to keep the forced labor alive and
well after all free labor is the dream
of any government so the new Russian
government was not about to give that up
and so the Googs were rebranded into
prison camps like polar wolf today more
than 700 of these forc labor prison
camps exist all across Russia found it
in 1961 on the site of the former 51st
gulg the first prisoners at polar wolf
were put to work in mind's loading sand
and gravel needed to build Railways
while the early 1970s polar wolf
consisted of a few cell blocks a medical
unit a laundry a checkpoint an ice house
and DM for the prison staff by the early
2000s the camp had grown big enough to
accommodate around a thousand inmates
and what else has changed in the 20
years since then no one really knows
over the last 20 years the only new
piece of information to come out of the
jail is that it now has a library a shop
and a church that's it that's all we
know and that is the point
as the Director of nal's anti-corruption
foundation put it all you need to do is
look at the map and you can see that
this is the northern most harshest
prison the very location means the
conditions there are the most severe
getting to car from Moscow means
spending one to 40 hours on a train if
you even manage to find one running to
the Village it's almost impossible to
get to this Colony it's almost
impossible to even send letters there
it's the highest possible level of
isolation from the world that's what
it's all about the complete isolation in
secrecy allows the people in charge to
keep inmates in some of the worst
conditions on Earth it since no one
knows what's really going on inside no
one can really do anything about
[Music]
this in 2021 a prisoner named Sergey
cilv was released from The Saratov
prison hospital Sergey spent more than 7
years in The Saratov prison on drug
charges but when prison staff found out
he was good with computers they assigned
him to work in the prison's it
Department part of his job was reviewing
video files that were shot on the
present staff's body cams but little did
the staff know that Sergey was also
secretly copying thousands of these
files onto a USB that he hid near the
present exits on the day of his release
Sergey managed to smuggle the USB out
with him and not long after he started
posting the footage online and the
videos he leaked were horrifying and
footage began to emerge from inside one
of Russia's most notorious
prisons
[Music]
the video showed prison guards and staff
torturing and abusing inmates in the
worst ways imaginable these videos are
so violent and graphic that it would
have definitely gotone this video
demonetized if we showed them but what
makes Serge's case so interesting is
that unlike the polar wolf prison camp
the catov prison hospital isn't found
somewhere in the middle of the Arctic
far away from civilization it's actually
just 450 Mi north of Moscow and it's
surrounded by dozens of big towns and
cities it's not even classified as a
prison camp it's just a regular jail so
if this kind of of use can happen out in
the open in a normal prison near a big
city just imagine how bad things are at
polar Wolf the prison where no one will
ever hear your screams according to
navali staff and a handful of imates who
were released from Polar wolf here's
what navali can expect as soon as you
cross the threshold they let you know
that you're in purgatory where you have
no rights and there is no one to
complain to beatings humiliation
electric shocks being kept in a cold
seal naked kit or in vet clothes but
that is still not the worst you can be
sealed in the fiddle position in an iron
box where you can hardly breathe and
have to urinate on yourself they
routinely threaten trop you when they
are bullying you as another inmate says
beatings are arriv soon after the
prisoners enter the jail and are
impossible to dodge according to present
staff they had to beat inmates right
from the start because
the prisoners must understand from the
first minutes where he ended
up and most of the time the caon threat
of beatings and assault works for
example if you refuse to sign article
106 under which prisoners can be forced
to work without pay they take you to
this bath house and undress you there is
a wooden bench there they hand cough you
to it and beat you until you sign but
that's not all in the winter prisoners
would be hastely assembled in the
courtyard in light clothing according to
the testimony of One X inmates they were
Healy information and not allowed to
clap or rub their hands together they
had to stand for 30 or 40 minutes
without moving when it was-
45° C or colder if one person moved the
whole group was dowed to his water in
polar wolf Collective punishment is a
standard if one prisoner misbehaves
everyone is punished and even once the
snow melts and summer comes along things
don't get any easier in the spring there
was a new torture mosquitoes and bit and
flies if you moved the hand to the water
came they would just Dow the whole group
with a water cannon the prison camps are
so bad that some prisoners would rather
un alive themselves than have to be
transferred there and these stories are
just bits and pieces that have slipped
through the cracks over the years it's
likely that the inmates at polar wolf go
through a lot worse they're just too
scared to talk and get sent back one
former inmate sums it up well there is a
road there on both sides of which there
is a cemetery read the word carp The
Village name in reverse and you will
understand what they turn people into in
Russian the word means dust I wouldn't
wish it on my worst
enemy and even though navali isn't a
violent criminal he will probably still
face the same treatment as everyone else
navoni will be held for at least a year
in a cell with a tiny exercise area from
which you cannot even see the sky said
one of his staff members and even if he
manages to keep himself alive it would
be very difficult for him to continue
opposing Putin from this Arctic jail
cell before navali arrived the only
communication between the prison and the
rest of the world was through the
Russian prison system cell service Zona
Telecom or you had to send letters
through Russia's regular postal service
but with the prison being this far from
civilization letters rarely arrive on
time or to the right address but in
another strange but not surprising
coincidence the prison cell service shut
down the same day nabali arrived so as
of right now it looks like Putin has won
his number one one critic has finally
been
silenced now although the US government
is thankfully not this openly evil the
US government is still not afraid to
cover up their dirty laundry as well
just take a look at what this former
LAPD detective had to say about the CIA
back in 1996 I will tell you director
deut has a former Los Angeles police
narcotics detective that the agency has
dealt drugs throughout this country for
a long
time director Deutsch I will refer you
to three specific agency operations
known as Amadeus Pegasus and Watchtower
I have Watchtower documents heavily
redacted by the agency I was personally
exposed to CIA operations and recruited
by CIA Personnel who attempted to
recruit me in the late '70s to become
involved in protecting agency drug
operations in this country I have been
trying to get this out for 18 years and
I have the evidence my question for you
is very specific sir if in the course of
the ig's investigations and Fred hit's
work you come across evidence of
severely criminal activity let him speak
and it's classified will you use that
classification to hide the criminal
activity or will you tell the American
people the truth yes he accused the CIA
of trafficking drugs onto the streets of
America but is there any truth to this
would the CIA really intentionally get
Americans addicted to crack cocaine well
we looked into it and as it turns out
yes there is a whole mountain of
evidence literal CIA operations of them
trafficking drugs in fact this is what
Chris Milligan a writer and the son of a
CIA officer who has spent years
investigating the link between the CIA
and drug trafficking had to say about it
do I think the CIA is still trafficking
drugs today yes I do uh but I think that
there's also a lot more people
trafficking drugs most every
intelligence agency and we expose it all
in our new private documentary that you
can watch right now by clicking the card
on the screen this is part of our
YouTube membership where we post only
the most controversial documentaries way
too spicy to be posted publicly we've
got a ton of great ones out already
these are videos you will never see
posted anywhere else and you are going
to love this one on CIA drug trafficking
so click the card on the screen to watch
now and as always stay
dangerous